[Musique]
vous allez le voir dans cette émission
avec deux universitaires
Mélanie clémond fontaine bonjour Patrice
université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
vous êtes en charge de la recherche
c'est ça
donc c'est important
et vous êtes spécialiste du numérique
tout à fait et on verra que le numérique
a une importance dans les œuvres d'art
claire boucléaire
histoire du droit à l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin alors vous avez
toutes les deux coordonnées avec
d'autres universitaires un livre qui est
un livre collectif avec beaucoup de
contribution qui s'appelle donc les
restitutions des collections muséales
aspects politiques et juridique
ces deux éditions Man et Martin c'est ça
oui qui est très bonne maison d'édition
déjà l'occasion de parler de quelques
livres qui sont publiés dans cette dans
cette vision d'édition on va aborder
évidemment l'histoire de de cette
restitution avec un discours important
que le discours de d'Emmanuel Macron à
Ouagadougou d'un rapport important qui
leur rapporte à savoir mais pourquoi
avoir voulu faire ce livre et consacrer
justement cette restitution
l'idée de des quatre personnes qui ont
porté ce livre d'abord ça ils avaient
ces quatre personnes ont des spécialités
différentes et donc de croiser leur
regard sur ce sur ce sujet un dans un
contexte où
le le débat se polarise comme souvent
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a les prostitutions
les contre-estitutions et donc nous en
tant que scientifique en tant que
chercheur nous avions envie de rendre
compte de la complexité en fait du sujet
et surtout entendre tous les points de
vue donc
réunir 19 auteurs il y a une préf
également faire une une
longue introduction qui expliquait tous
les enjeux
et finalement fournir un terreau un
terreau de réflexion pour ceux qui
s'intéressent à au sujet afin de se
constituer une opinion
peut-être revenir sur
l'histoire de la question de cette
institutions on en parle depuis des
années moi je me souviens oui que que
Arnaud Klarsfeld devait parler à propos
de ce qui se passait auprès de d'oeuvres
qui étaient en Angleterre qui voulait
restituer
comment comment ce comment
s'explique cette histoire justement
alors cette question de restitutions
elle est au fond très ancienne elle est
liée au départ au droit de butin qui
permet de manière légitime à un peuple
victorieux de d'arracher les hommes
les oeuvres de ceux qui ont perdu la
guerre et Cicéron s'en empare des son
discours sur les oeuvres d'art contre
vérès
mais aussi pour souligner c'est un
discours qui a été écrit à propos de du
pillage de la Sicile
et qui est assez intéressant parce qu'on
voit bien que il y a tout de même des
questions éthiques qui se posent et ici
le fait d'un pillage un peu systématique
et qui profitait au chef c'était un peu
ça ce que le 600 accusés non oui surtout
que le pillage était systématique
important et qu'effectivement il mettait
en cause vérès
particulièrement
mais la question elle a elle a rebondi
sous diverses formes et au fond
aujourd'hui elle se pose dans des les
conditions
qui sont différentes de celles de la
guerre tel qu'on peut classiquement
l'entendre
et qui prend pas exactement les mêmes
formes
ça change que il peut y avoir du pillage
mais il peut y avoir aussi des échanges
marchands et c'est dans le cas c'est le
cas d'ailleurs dans le cas du patrimoine
africain il y a dans certains cas des
échanges marchands et puis il peut y
avoir aussi du pillage
cette question elle est elle a rebondi
en quelque sorte dans les années 70 du
fait d'un discours assez majeur
prononcer l'UNESCO par le directeur
général
Amadou Tambo reproduit dans l'entourage
voilà parce qu'il y a une certaine un
certain nombre dans l'ouvrage de pièces
en quelque sorte à conviction
d'éléments qui permettent
au néophytes de relire des textes
importants sur le sujet donc et puis
également la loi sur les restitutions de
descente 2020
alors ce discours de de l'UNESCO il a
permis que cette question
soit posée dans les cercles de la
culture mais en réalité
dans les années 80 on a même été jusqu'à
créer des formulaires de restitution
mais il n'y a pas eu
véritablement de matérialisation de
cette réflexion et donc elle a rebondi
du fait de demande de restitution qui
sont soulevées par certains pays comme
c'était le cas pour le Bénin depuis 2016
et du fait du discours du président
Emmanuel Macron à Ouagadougou qui
en 2017 fin 2017 voilà oui l'annonce
qu'il y aura en réalité des restitutions
ce qui peut effectivement paraître
surprenant en tout cas pour un juriste
parce que c'est ce patrimoine est entré
dans le patrimoine français et qu'il y a
des règles assez précises pour l'en
faire ressortir parce que il est frappé
d'inaldiabilité
c'est-à-dire que jusqu'à présent le
certains États tels que la France se
sente responsable de ses collections
vont ériger même des musées consacrés à
ces collection le musée du cadrani et
donc
se présente comme un peu les sauveurs
de ce patrimoine et là
le président pose une rupture en disant
ben non en fait je reconnais
la revendication des restitutions
jusqu'à présent ses contenter de vous
prêter ces collections parce que elle
faisait partie effectivement d'un
domaine public inaliable on a des règles
on a des écrins pour les conserver et
bien en définitive vous pouvez le faire
vous même et donc c'est c'est non
seulement ce discours il est
symboliquement fort mais il va être
suivi aussi d'action et notamment la
commande d'un rapport qui est
juste une phrase du discours je ne peux
pas accepter qu'une large part de du
patrimoine culturel de plusieurs pays
africains soient en France c'est une
c'est direct
une forme d'émotion
chez un certain nombre de directeurs de
musées parce que au fond c'est
l'ouverture d'une boîte dont on ne sait
pas si ça ne va pas être une boîte de
Pandore parce que il n'y a pas
de cas unique de l'Afrique et qu'au fond
des demandes de restitution elles
peuvent arriver de toute de toute
avec parfois des dangers on y viendra
peut-être tout à l'heure des risques on
dirait peut-être mais ce que vous dire
enfin c'est quand même un changement de
paradigme enfin un changement de
théorie quoi oui et donc à partir de là
tout va s'accélérer il y a une loi qui
est adoptée en 2020 pour acter la
restitution il y a donc le discours il y
a le rapport ça à savoir ça
un intellectuel sénégalaise
spécialiste d'histoire de l'art et qui a
déjà s'emparer déjà de ce sujet
mais qui va écrire particulièrement ce
rapport sous l'angle de de l'art
africain d'accord et qu'est-ce qui dit
ce rapport alors
ce rapport il est
assez engagé au sens où il appelle à une
restitution assez large des biens il en
donne parfois d'ailleurs la nature
spécifique mais dans ce rapport le volet
était assez mince et on pouvait
reprocher à ce rapport d'élever une
forme de présomption
au flux de prédation de prédation et de
présomption de prédation
les pays occidentaux étaient présumés
où il y a des règles justement pour des
objets qui auraient été recueillis de
façon illégitime depuis parce que
bulletin de guerre c'est devenu éligible
parce que vol etc donc tout cela et que
tu en garderait en revanche il y a des
objets qui ont été collectionnés de
façon tout à fait légale et qui
maintenant tombe sous le coup de d'un
régime protecteur qui les rend
inaliénable et donc c'est ce rapport il
est
igom un peu cette peut-être cette cette
nuance pardon excusez-moi
les objets ça nous concerne pas les
objets actuels qu'on pourrait prendre
cette console des objets anciens si je
peux dire
les objets qui sont actuellement dans
les musées et qui vont être qui pourrait
être rendu sur le sur un fondement
par exemple qu'on a pas l'origine on
peut pas prouver l'origine de ces biens
et de ce fait à ce moment-là il y aurait
une forme de présomption donc
sinon on doit montrer que ce patrimoine
est entré de manière légitime sachant
qu'on n'a pas forcément une
documentation même si sur certains
certaines quêtes certaines collectes on
a tout à fait des
on a tout à fait sur des objets
Branly il y a une partie de des objets
qui viennent de la collecte qui a été
opérée
par l'expédition dakarjibouti et que
certains cahiers ont été tenus
assez précis
donc on a on a des éléments de
traçabilité de provenance mais on n'a
pas forcément pour chaque objet ces
éléments et ce rapport reviendrait
à placer les musées dans l'obligation de
faire la preuve de la provenance qui
n'est pas forcément évidente alors il y
a donc ce discours il y a ce rapport et
puis il y a la loi sur le Bénin je crois
que vous dites dans le livre il est
assez surréaliste parce qu'il y a comme
ça une liste d'objets un peu comme un
poème la Prévert
simplement cette loi elle nécessaire
pour sortir cette liste d'objets du
patrimoine public et afin de vous
permettre la restitution donc c'est elle
tient en quelques lignes elle est
essentiellement constituée de la liste
des objets du fait du principe parce
qu'en réalité pour pour extraire ces
objets il faut une décision qui ne soit
pas simplement celle du président
Emmanuel Macron mais qui soit celle
du Parlement
est-ce que cette loi justement elle a
pas un peu qui était les collection les
musées alors je pense que cette loi elle
est apparue comme une forme de compromis
acceptable parce que au départ on
parlait pas de restituer 26 objets mais
il y avait une dimension beaucoup plus
inquiétante dans le rapport ça Savoie et
qu'au fond il y a eu un compromis
un compromis acceptable parce que je
pense aussi qu'il est que les lignes
bougent et qu'on est sensible au fait
que un Afrique des musées soit édifié
pour conserver des objets qui n'étaient
pas forcément facile de conserver
jusqu'à présent
et dans des conditions qui sécurisent
ces objets
et c'est une question quand même assez
cruciale et donc
cette loi vient rappeler l'inallier
d'habilité
l'intangibilité de ce principe et au
fond ça c'est une part du compromis on
rend 26 objets mais on rappelle que le
principe d'Inal inhababilité un principe
majeur du droit français et justement
dans le débat démocratique actuel on en
parle beaucoup de la démocratie et des
règles de démocratiques c'est
intéressant de voir ce processus puisque
on a un discours de président de la
République mais la décision elle est
prise par le Parlement c'est une loi
adoptée par le Parlement c'est pour ça
que quand je disais le ciel vous aviez
raison de dire non il y a un processus
démocratique
engagé c'est quand même une parole
politique très forte s'engage il a l'air
de d'y aller en force quelque part c'est
comme ça que ça pu être ressenti il
n'empêche qu'on a des procédures qui
font que le Parlement réintervient et
donc on peut trouver des voies médianes
et y aller
étape par étape
la position des pays
dont les pays africains qui sont les qui
sont les producteurs de ces œuvres
justement est-ce que c'est une position
qui est à peu près la même dans tous les
pays où est-ce qu'il y a des différences
il y a eu plusieurs il y a il y a le
sentiment de d'être dépossédé on parle
de 80% de d'objets qui seraient hors des
frontières donc c'est énorme mais
vraiment une disproportionnalité très
très importante il y a toute toute
l'histoire coloniale et donc cette
nécessité de se réapproprier le discours
qui accompagne ses objets
c'est raconter son histoire par avec ses
propres mots ça c'est extrêmement
important ça sert bien ensuite je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de vision monolithique
et même sur des territoires donnés et
deux articles sont consacrés
au sabre rendu au Sénégal et on voit
bien que ça a créé une discussion assez
polémique sur l'origine effective du
sabre à ce qu'il s'agissait bien du
sabre parce que la provenance de cet
objet douteuse mais ensuite sur place ça
exacerbait des tensions
parce que ce sabre ce sabre était
extrêmement symbolique et donc
de
l'action des musulmans sur le territoire
et donc il y a eu une forme de réaction
qui s'est opérée avec la remise du sable
si bien que ça permet de voir à quel
point le sujet est complexe il y a
effectivement des des
demandes de restitution et je dirais je
rejoins totalement Mélanie sur le fait
que
le fait d'en parler va véritablement
constituer pour ces populations la
perception d'après judice culturel
au-delà du cercle étroit au départ
qui était celui des tenants des
restitutions mais il y a des demandes
qui sont qui vont être de récupérer
des schémas de tapis pas les tapis
eux-mêmes mais les schémas pour pouvoir
se les réapproprier il va y avoir des
demandes qui vont être beaucoup plus
mais bon
plus nuancées parce que il y a des
objets qui sont des objets de culte qui
sont partis du territoire et qu'il est
complexe de faire revenir donc c'est ce
sont des questions vraiment très
compliqué je dirais une phrase justement
sur ces objets de culte c'est quelqu'un
qui dit les masques et les fétiches qui
sont aujourd'hui entreposés dans les
musées européens il ne servirait à rien
de les rendre car ces pièces n'ont
aucune valeur pour les Africains ils
sont vides morts des envoutées ils ont
perdu leur sens originel parce qu'ils
ont été arrachés de leur contexte ils
sont donc devenus des objets sans
signification alors ça c'est le discours
qu'on peut tenir d'ailleurs il y a
des objets qui ont été abandonnés mais
en fait l'abandon peut faire partie
aussi d'un processus c'est-à-dire que
abandonner un masque c'est un retour à
la nature c'est un cycle et donc c'est
pas un comme nous nous pouvons
l'entendre un bien sans mettre qu'on
peut s'approprier donc il y a des
conceptions aussi très très différentes
par rapport à la propriété selon les
cultures et puis pour rebondir sur ce
que dit claire il y a ce sont des
négociations aujourd'hui qui se situent
au niveau des États mais ces objets ils
sont attachés à des communautés et ces
communautés peuvent ne pas correspondre
aux frontières étatiques donc on voit
bien quand même que c'est extrêmement
sensible d'autant quand on a des objets
qui sont comme ça porteurs ou qui ont
été qui ont été le support de de
d'éléments magiques d'éléments religieux
etc donc il y a notre ami Philippe
Charlier fait des études sur les
aliments qu'on retrouve sur ces
sculptures c'est passionnant c'est c'est
ce sont des lui il en parle comme des
sculptures vivantes qui ont un tube
digestif qui qui soit qui voilà qui ont
qui ont un aura donc c'est c'est
toute cette complexité qu'il faut
nécessaire de voilà de tenir compte ce
ne sont pas des
œuvres qui viennent juste
agréable à regarder c'est plus que ça
justement mais c'est pour ça que c'est
la question
on se souvient du discours ça n'avait
rien à voir avec l'art mais de de
Nicolas Sarkozy à Dakar je crois que
disait les pays africains ne sont pas
encore rentrés dans l'histoire mais il y
a souvent eu même si les spécialistes de
l'Africain l'idée que au fond il n'y
avait pas forcément un Africain que
c'était de la reproduction c'était pas
de la création que de la reproduction
sans cesse des mêmes œuvres et donc il y
avait parfois une négation de du côté
artistique pour un côté plutôt artisanal
quoi je voudrais juste rebondir sur ce
point parce que je vous pose la question
en fait c'est ces objets
on différente nature donc on peut pas
avoir un discours globalisant sur ces
objets il y en a qui ont une charge
magique il y en a qui me vieux charge
historique on a une charge esthétique et
donc la difficulté de d'être nuancée
c'est que ces objets peuvent avoir une
aussi une
dimension marchande et là ils deviennent
du coup un bien et avec des enjeux
marchands très importants donc c'est on
est toujours à la à la frontière de ce
qui est de la de la culture de l'accès à
la culture de l'accès à l'histoire et
puis et bien c'est ces enjeux marchands
qu'il faut pas négliger non plus
parce que ce sont les marchands qui ont
participé à la diffusion de ce
patrimoine en Occident qui l'ont inséré
je pense par exemple à Paul Guillaume
qui l'ont inséré ce patrimoine dans la
création
occidentale Picasso on en parle et on y
reviendra mais extrêmement oui
et de la question des masques
on peut également voir cette fascination
chez Hergé qui reprend
le masque pour lui
contribution dans ce livre notamment
vous faites ce détour qui pourrait
sembler un peu
anecdotique ou c'est pas par Hergé par
Tintin alors je pense que s'il est
justement pas anecdotique parce que
voilà parce que aujourd'hui la bande
dessinée d'Hergé constitue en quelque
sorte une source pour l'historien et
je vous laisse la parole mais c'est vrai
que dans beaucoup d'albums de Tintin les
les rôles et puis il y a des prédateurs
aussi de côté tombent sur des œuvres
d'art des pays qui visitent c'est ça
alors il y a intérêt évident pour Hergé
pour l'objet et donc il y a toutes
sortes d'objets phares et des objets qui
vont constituer le fil rouge d'un album
c'est le cas avec le sceptre d'autocar
et c'est le cas aussi dans l'oreille
cassé
des albums et dès les Cigares du pharaon
du reste
Hergé se pose la question de de la
légitimité de l'appropriation du bien
qui appartient à la culture qui n'est
pas la sienne et en même temps il pose
dans toutes ces questions de traverse
une grande partie des albums la question
de policiers entre cultures et du fait
que certains de ces objets peuvent être
le témoignage de l'amitié entre deux
cultures c'est d'ailleurs le cas dans
l'oreille cassée
puisque au fond on leur a qui s'est
raconté l'histoire d'un bien qui
disparaît du musée ethnologique de
Bruxelles le fétiche
et Tintin par la à la recherche de ce
fétiche qui l'amène jusque chez les
arômes Bayards et on découvre il y a une
page entière qui s'intéresse à la
traçabilité à la provenance du fétiche
et ce fétiche a été donné à un
explorateur il y a donc c'est un objet
qui est rentré dans le patrimoine belge
de manière parfaitement légitime donc en
réalité a été lui-même très intéressé
par le Musée
des Arts
de Bruxelles et également le Musée de
Tervuren qu'il avait beaucoup inspiré
pour le Congo parce qu'il avait pas
énormément de documentation
cette question il avait pas tellement
appréhendé dans le Congo mais le Congo
malgré tous les reproches qui sont faits
à cet album est un album très
intéressant
historiquement parce qu'il correspond au
moment de l'expédition Dakar Djibouti et
que au fond tata d'une certaine façon
par à l'aventure voilà l'année 30
exactement donc Dakar Djibouti c'est
1931 et
aujourd'hui il y a un documentaire que
je conseille à tout le monde
qui est un élément passionnant
aujourd'hui
exactement un documentaire sur Arte qui
est très intéressant sur le sujet parce
qu'on y voit beaucoup d'images de cette
des photos on a gardé finalement on a
réussi à conserver peu de documents
filmés parce qu'il y avait eu des films
pendant l'expédition mais on a quand
même un grand nombre de documentations
ce qui fait que le film est extrêmement
riche sur le plan documentaire et je
conseille d'aller jusque jusqu'à enfin
du documentaire parce que il y a des
précisions qui sont données en fin de
documentaire sur les sur les documents
les traces qu'on a cette expédition et
elle permet vraiment à mon sens d'entrer
dans dans la complexité du sujet parce
qu'on y voit Michel Leiris et d'autres
parties collectées sur place des biens
on sent aussi qu'il y a une certaine
pression à la collecte c'est-à-dire
qu'ils doivent ils doivent ramener des
objets c'est quand même leur mission et
c'est une mission qui est financée
et on voit bien au cours de cette
expédition qu'ils vont être
au départ pris plutôt dans des relations
marchandes très bien accueillies aussi
mais que un certain moment il perdent en
quelque sorte
l'esprit original qui était le leur
c'est à dire un esprit plutôt anti
colonialiste et ils font des reproches
au colonialisme et eux-mêmes vont décidé
à certains moments de s'emparer de bien
et parfois ils partent la nuit pour
éviter des questions parfois avec
l'accord de la population mais ils
sentent bien que cet accord qu'il
détienne se consentement et fragile
qu'il pourrait bien en une nuit
se modifier et donc c'est un c'est un
documentaire qui est extrêmement
intéressant
d'ailleurs de ce qu'ils achètent
justement
c'est pas la provenance mais là
il se plaignent ils se plaignent de du
caractère fastidieux les commentaires de
faire des inventaires et par ailleurs un
moment donné on voit le documentaire
montre combien d'objets ont été prélevés
mais là je crois qu'il faudrait être un
peu plus précis parce que vous allez
avoir des objets qui peuvent avoir comme
le disait Mélanie des charges
extrêmement diverses et donc au musée de
Tervueren vous avez énormément d'objets
euh qui qui sont des objets de cuisine
et qui vont être investis par ces
ethnologues
non seulement ils achètent l'objet il y
a quand même un certain nombre de
ventes
on voit dans le dans le documentaire on
voit un moment donné un Africain qui
porte sur son torse une clé qui est une
clé occidentale et on peut imaginer
qu'il a échangé et
comme comme on pouvait échanger des
perles
on peut avoir quelque chose de nouveau
c'est plutôt voilà
et ça ça nourrit quand même l'idée que
l'Occident était là pour conserver tous
ces tous patrimoine et donc on est en
train de changer de
d'approche avec surtout des États qui
maintenant ont construit des musées
incroyables
pour accueillir la question de la
conservation qui est important des
arguments
on a dit à un moment qu'il avait
probablement apporté des choses un peu
on nous faisait si je faisais
flou sur sur des objets mais c'est vrai
qu'il y avait beaucoup de peut-être de
de d'amoureux de ces armes ce qu'on
appelle les arts premiers maintenant on
a peur à un moment il y a pu avoir une
fascination thème parce que les
marchands sont sont aujourd'hui pour sur
certains objets les marchands vont
apporter une expertise qui est énorme et
certainement que sur place certains
marchands n'ont pas ces non cédé à la
tentation
de prendre des objets
qui les fascine est tellement
qui pouvait opérer
une forme de prélèvement
illégitime mais ça n'empêche pas on le
voit bien d'ailleurs dans le cahier
quand même
de qui est
retraçait dans l'expédition
Dakar Djibouti ça n'empêche pas que dans
cette expédition on voit vraiment que la
population est totalement appelée à
participer non seulement à échanger des
objets mais à raconter leur histoire
également éventuellement des comptes
populaires et donc à documenter l'objet
donc l'objet est une manière d'entrer
dans la culture de l'autre et de mieux
la comprendre
et ça revient sur cette recherche de
compréhension mutuelle
et patrimoine universel ou finalement ça
n'appartient à personne c'est ça fait
partie de l'intercullité mondiale pour
vivre ensemble comme on imaginerait pas
un musée où ignorer que aujourd'hui un
musée en France où il n'y aurait que de
l'air français
évidemment
ces populations qui considèrent que un
certain nombre de ces objets sont des
objets ambassadeur
et donc des objets qu'on peut avoir
intérêt à laisser dans des musées
occidentaux
et qui montre la beauté de cette culture
parce que il y a un point d'entrée dans
cette musique il y a actuellement dans
l'art contemporain une faveur assez
grande pour leur contemporain africains
notamment
[Musique]
mais est-ce que ça change justement le
regard des pays africains justement sur
ces parce que là aussi ça devient
mondialisme mondialisé cette africain si
je peux dire
que c'est pour sortir aussi du passé
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a il y a vraiment
un travail à faire de par rapport à la
colonisation qui est une blessure très
très profonde et en même temps qui qui
vient retenir dans le passé donc là
contemporain parce que l'Afrique comme
l'ensemble du monde et finalement
très un terreau de créativité énorme et
donc là comme ailleurs et mettre en
valeur cette créativité contemporaine
c'est aussi s'inscrire dans le présent
ça n'a pas à mon sens plus de
spécificité que la création ailleurs il
faut
essayer
africains sur eux-mêmes aussi
d'une autre façon et aussi de le à la
fois de le sublimer et de le surmonter
de façon positive tout à fait donc il y
a un certain nombre de ces artistes
du PC pour
par exemple prendre un masque et en
faire quelque chose d'autre prennent pas
le masque qui est dans le musée mais il
s'inspire du masque pour proposer une
variante contemporaine de ce masque et
certains souhaitent permettre que leurs
œuvres contemporaines retrouvent
l'espace du sacré et donc ils vont
essayer d'insérer leur création
contemporaine dans les cérémonies
rituels
qui sont les leurs et qui cherchent
aussi à réinvestir et en complément de
ça c'est pas non plus une fin en soi
c'est-à-dire qui peut y avoir un lien
avec de la création traditionnelle mais
il y a aussi toute une création qui est
totalement
voilà plus générique et c'est important
de le dire parce que sinon on est un peu
dans le folklore ce qui est ce qui est
très réducteur de la création d'une
dynamisme créatif un mot
l'apport du numérique dans ce sur ce
sujet alors l'apport du numérique on a
parlé de rayonnement ça c'est très
important puisque on est quand même dans
un une société ou de l'accès au savoir à
la culture se fait via le numérique donc
la numérisation des collections muséales
c'est un enjeu extrêmement important et
c'est important aussi pour ces
collections dans dans le cadre de des
réflexions autour de la restitution
parce que que ça permet une ambiguïté
des objets c'est à dire que ces objets
quel que soit finalement le support
physique et la situation géographique du
support physique on va au moins avoir
accès à ces objets numériquesment avec
aussi des outils incroyables qui sont la
possibilité d'agrandir la possibilité de
tourner autour la possibilité de créer
des objets 3D donc des reproductions
assez fidèles alors c'est des c'est des
copies mais enfin je pense qu'il y a les
musées sont remplis de copies et on s'en
rend pas compte donc il faut c'est
relativiser
la question de l'original bref c'est
c'est numérisation c'est important mais
c'est un coût aussi très important et
c'est là toute la difficulté de qui
accompagne cette question d'une de la
numérisation c'est à dire qu'on a des
institutions publiques qui doit
fonctionner et numériser non pas les
moyens
or quand est le numérise ce sont des
données publiques et donc c'est
accessible à tous tout le monde peut les
réutiliser donc on est vraiment voilà on
est vraiment dans la finalité du musée
qui est de rendre accessible à tous et à
toutes en revanche comme les
institutions n'ont pas forcément les
moyens elles vont faire appel
éventuellement à des sociétés
extérieures qui là peuvent monnayer une
exclusivité de l'exploitation finalement
de la numérisation c'est double
numérique donc on voit que la question
est complexe et je regardais un
documentaire sur sur un justement cette
question de restitution et la
revendication allait jusqu'à l'empreinte
numérique en disant restituer l'objet et
puis aussi tous ces doubles toutes ces
empreintes numériques des œuvres parce
que c'est vraiment un coût très
important et là était introduit la
question de la propriété intellectuelle
on va pas rentrer dans le détail mais il
n'empêche que c'est finalement on aurait
pu espérer que le numérique permet de
s'émanciper de l'appropriation de la
réservation du monopole et puis on
s'aperçoit que par des règles juridiques
par des motivations économiques
finalement va encore mettre des
blocages
empêcher l'accès
on a une propriété personnelle d'un
objet numérique non là ça permet de
d'identifier d'authentification
je mettrai un bémol je pense qu'il y
aura quand même beaucoup de résistance
des conservateurs de musées on le voit
avec la frise du Parthénon entre
l'Angleterre et la Grèce ou
toujours l'autisme c'est ça alors son
emplacement vide
et Athènes un musée vide qui qui attend
et c'est les discussions avancent mais
il y a eu des propositions faites dans
le sens de réalisation 3D et de boîte de
d'entreprises privées qui se sont
insérées dans ces débats et le
direction du British Museum a mis un
bémol à ça en disant que un musée ne
pouvait pas alors Mélanie disait il y a
des copies dans les musées mais
normalement
quand on présente quelque chose c'est
qu'on croit à la solidité de la
provenance et ce que je veux dire c'est
en tout cas moi comme public je ne
serais pas toujours capable de faire
le risque et
c'est parce que vous savez qu'à un
moment donné on va dupliquer ce fétiche
et Tintin va finir par le retrouver dans
une boutique à 17 francs
et il y a toute une réflexion très
intéressante de sa part sur le fait de
dupliquer l'objet et sa valeur
évidemment chute et au fond la morale de
cet album on le voit à la fin l'objet
c'est c'est
le fétiche premier qui était retrouvé
qui est tout abîmé il a explosé en éclat
parce qu'il y avait un en fait il était
le contenant d'un trésor
et donc il est il a été en quelque sorte
reconstitué mais c'est bien le fétiche
premier avec toutes ces griffures toutes
toutes ces
toutes ces brisures qu'on a
reconstituées et et malgré le fait qu'il
soit très abîmé c'est ce fétiche qu'on
expose et surtout pas une
la numérisation aussi permet de de
reconstituer ce qui a été détruit
définitivement on en voit les rues de
Palmyre par exemple ça c'est incroyable
ce qu'on a pu faire et ça c'est un
intérêt scientifique c'est un intérêt
historique donc ce sont des outils qu'il
faut pas négliger pas du tout mais si le
rayonnement de l'objet et pas le même
c'est merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
je renvoie au livre donc les
restitutions des collections musiales
aspects politiques et juridique c'est
donc c'est Mané
Mania à chaque fois Marie et Martin avec
un petit comme ça merci merci à toutes
les deux merci et puis voilà puis vous
revenez quand vous voulez merci
[Musique]